today's guest uh i'm grateful to finally
have her in studio um she is from
atlanta but has been living in indiana
for quite some time uh we'll hear more
about it uh she is the creator and star
of the miss pat show which is currently
on bet plus
and paramount plus she also has her new
special on netflix you can check it out
it's called y'all want to hear something
crazy
she's my new friend and she brought some
beautiful ladies with her i'll say that
some real lookers
um
the hilarious miss path
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
um so you're moving back to atlanta are
you excited are you um i just moved back
i am excited um
i shoot the show there i shoot the miss
pat show there and i shot my special day
i'm from atlanta so my husband just
retired and i was like look i'm ready to
get [ __ ] out of indiana let's go home
yeah so i bought some i bought some land
and i'm building on it dang
what y'all gonna have like anything
special at the house like anything you
always wanted um i wanted a podcast
studio because right now i was doing it
i was doing it a little bit everywhere i
do it on zoom and then when i was in
indy i would do it out of my movie
theater room so i really want to get big
time like you and everybody else so i
built the podcast studio um outside the
house oh nice yeah and y'all gonna have
what else a pool
a pool a basketball court oh nice it's
gonna be all right yeah
you got any fancy neighbors like is it
in a fancy place no it's not in a fancy
place 12 people every the youngest
person might be 65 at y'all's house
little small neighborhood and it had
some a couple acreages and i just bought
it damn i knew i wanted a big house but
i didn't want a big mortgage yeah so i
just found some land and i told the
house down and i'm gonna get with it
damn and who's gonna live at the house
with you your husband you um i have four
kids that i have custody of my niece
kids and then i have a 21 or 22 and a 23
year old damn they have three grandkids
uh and my son they live nearby yeah your
life's crazy i felt even just a half
hour of your your special i felt like i
watched it like it remind me of the wire
remember that show
oh yeah i was it took a long time for me
to get into the wire me too my husband
is a christian i mean he grew up
christian so and i grew up you know of
course selling drugs you know my
background and he was kept raving about
you got to wash his shoulder i don't
want to watch that [ __ ] i love that
[ __ ] and one day i sit down and i watch
the wire i was like oh my god this [ __ ]
is so [ __ ] real yeah they did a good
job they did a good [ __ ] job but i
think i got into it like in the fourth
season oh yeah really yeah yeah oh yeah
i didn't get into it i don't think until
like one year ago really yeah oh my god
that's that's one of the best
underrated shows that was out there and
it was so [ __ ] real yeah i could
really relate you know what show i
really missed was in the heat of the
night do you remember that show i do
remember you don't know i remember that
show yeah it was good huh you're telling
your age theory
what i'm showing my age yeah oh yeah
sorry that's why they need to do a
remake so i can sound really like i know
what like i just miss i
dude i saw the lady from in the heat of
the night one time eating breakfast with
her husband
i lost my mind do you remember the
detective his wife
not quite you know who i remember from
the heat of the night is the uh the
black dude and then the officer the
other other one oh yeah carol o'connor
you're carol o'connell
the black guy virgil tibbs that was his
name his wife was althea and i saw her
at the breakfast place and i really lost
it oh wow i've never heard nobody say
they was crazy about the heat of the
night yeah i loved it
i really loved it my [ __ ] was dukes of
hazzle back in that area really i had
you like them country boys well i'm from
the south and you know uh everybody's
going crazy over daisy duke you know
because i was really young and um the
boys were going crazy uh uh beau duke is
who i thought was [ __ ] drop gorgeous
damn oh i had the biggest crush on bo
duke let's pull him up colin can we get
bo duke up there
back in the day and one of them is a uh
homosexual man i think isn't he
one of them loved men yeah or preferred
men
where do you get this they didn't say it
oh i think everybody knows it i think
the one with the black hair
i think he might have been
i don't tell me my baby daddy i know i
think you might have been lusting after
that man man
that's bull right there one with the
blonde hair yeah what about the picture
with that hat with just a nose shirt on
oh everybody loved bo duke bacon today
yeah he was good huh yeah
i think they down in georgia aren't they
um i don't know
bo duke
i don't know one of them i think
preferred me and i could be wrong but
i don't know so
so your husband i heard you met him and
he was in the military and then uh
and and now he's done he's retired he
retired he um he um what was he six
seven years in the military or something
like that and when i met him he had just
got out so he was really young
and um he worked for general motors he
makes the allison transmission for the
military division oh wow and so he
retired about two two three months ago
dang in december he retired is it weird
because some people say when people get
retired then it gets weird around the
house because somebody's around more but
i'm never around so i'm just like
literally i do i do morning radio fv 103
in atlanta and then i gotta leave there
and i go to set and if i'm not doing sit
i'm i'm [ __ ] traveling but it's a
little weird having him home during the
day i think he's bored out his mind and
i'm like what do you want to do i'm cool
i'm cool like you want to come see me
take the show cause he's in front of a
live studio audience i'm cool i'm cool
so i just i think he's just got a jest
because my husband's so used to being
head of the household and he's been
working a whole [ __ ] marriage since
i've known him and this is first time
nev not having a job yeah so i think
he's kind of
a jest to the [ __ ] yeah
yeah i got to get a wife or something
one day i um yeah i only ever been with
one black woman in my life and uh
she had like you know it's legal i know
i know yeah yeah
ain't nobody stop you theo
that mullet you rocking might be
stopping
[Laughter]
a black woman [ __ ] a white dude with a
[ __ ] oh we about to change the
game man you need to cut that
[ __ ] mullet oh i don't know
baby this is really my fire powers in
there well you need to explain to the
black get my fire power it ain't what
you thinking okay okay
yeah yeah no it's not like a racist
emblem it's just my i just feel more
confident well you don't have on the
confederate flag but it's just it's the
haircut it is huh black women's are very
petite about what they mean look like
yeah you never that's why you never
that's why you never really see black
men with dirty shoes
they just ain't got no money right but
if you fly you're gonna always see black
men with clean shoes on yeah black
people always smell real exciting
and exciting
yeah oh dude you know if a [ __ ]
you'll meet a brother he smells like a
damn bath and body works you know what
i'm saying sometimes black people
i feel like they a lot of times they
just are more
yeah flashy flashy yeah we you know like
why is it why is it
is it just because we make everything
look good yeah i mean if you want to
sell something let's be honest who you
take it to you take it to the
african-american uh you take it to the
black people because we make everything
flash blood how are you doing that wrong
yeah i mean think about it how many
white athletes got a shoe
um
oh your boy um tom brady had some uggs
yeah yeah yeah that's true
and then uh oh boy larry bird had the
converse and only because him and um
magic had that thing going on back in
here yeah
it's really hard you gotta i don't think
black people buy a white shoe that's a
good point huh yeah because you know we
we you want something to sell you taking
it off damn huh
yeah we walk in advertisement all the
time we turn anything hot and fresh yeah
huh yeah i think i uh people always look
to the black community for like what's
cool huh
what were the coolest people on earth
yeah
nobody's cooler than us that's why we
cop it
yeah let me think who else could be
maybe aliens i heard somewhere that
black people and aliens don't get along
did you ever hear is that like a thing
in the black culture do you really think
alien is [ __ ] real
i mean
they got it they got to have some of
them well how many how many times do you
think a black person made an alien
i don't know do you know anything
[ __ ] no are you serious
i don't know if you guys are telling not
saying something oh who the [ __ ] yeah i
think it knows this white people y'all
[ __ ] know if it was aliens
before us we mind all [ __ ] kids
you ain't never heard no black people
i'm just gonna go to the moon and [ __ ]
with these people in the sky
that's white people [ __ ] that ain't all
[ __ ] the [ __ ] are you talking yeah
that's probably true aliens and black
people don't get along what the [ __ ]
that's supposed to be i don't know
that's just what i heard that's like
something i heard through the grapevine
over the years that's like an old wives
tale or something you know well let me
well i've heard all white men dixie
small that ain't true is it no well
thank you yeah yeah yeah yeah
you hurry up and defend that no
absolutely not
oh that's wild
um
what else is going on today
not much really just chilling pretty
much you know
i'm trying to think of something else
super that's exciting so you got your
special out yeah yeah and i watched
about 30 minutes of it last night it was
awesome you tell so many jokes i mean
you just
thank you um robert townsend directed it
and um
it wasn't easy getting together with him
boy he worked the [ __ ] out of me really
i had to meet with him once once a week
for four hours a day on zoom and do my
whole set and he would take it and twist
it he would listen to every set i did
out on the road and hit me back that
monday and said this is what we're gonna
work on this wednesday are you serious
yes i've never heard of a director doing
that i haven't either but
you know to step to robert townsend and
say you want him to direct your special
when he only did raw for eddie murphy uh
i think i hope i said the right one for
eddie murphy but he did eddie murphy raw
and he did bill cosby last one to step
to say you want him to direct your
special that was huge wow and he was
like no and i was like i need you i knew
i just needed him you know i just felt
like he was a director that would care
that would sit down this is my first
special i really wanted to be good
and
it took a minute but he finally came
through and he directed it for me and it
was not easy work wow he really put you
through it he put me through it i mean
and so i was supposed to tape it a year
earlier but the pandemic hit yeah so he
came on right after the rat after the
pandemic hit i think and he worked the
dog [ __ ] out of me damn i would call him
again if i got another special because
you know when you drop a space you
really worry about you know do people
don't think it's funny is it gonna flow
right i didn't watch it i watched the
cuts and put together but i don't really
want to be you know because i'm scared
i'm scared what people are going to
think about it yeah and i just started
to look at the feedback and people oh my
god it's so good it's so funny just joe
it reminds me of comedy back in the day
and you know because i'm not i'm not i
say what the [ __ ] i want to say oh yeah
you do for sure more than anybody i
think i've heard in a long time yeah so
i mean you know the council culture
um they out there i mean
i'm not worried about them i'm gonna say
what the [ __ ] i want to say you digest
it how the [ __ ] you want to see it yeah
and um one of the things uh that was
really robert really liked the thing i
did at the end i don't know if you got
to the end my daughter is gay and um i
tell all of these bits about my daughter
being gay and i do this whole speech at
the end about
you know
um
which
at first i didn't think they was gonna
take it so i said i said no matter what
you've been through in life learn how to
laugh at it i don't give a [ __ ] and
somebody stuck their thumb up your ass
if they didn't get past the knuckle you
won yeah
and netflix was like what the [ __ ]
but that's what i've been saying on
stage
with that hour i had for the longest
because i mean i won't i don't give a
[ __ ] what you've been through yeah you
can get through it if you believe that
you can get through it the mind is a
strong muscle it take on what you put in
it yeah if you say i'm depressed it
gonna be it going your mind will make
your whole body depressed so i don't use
words like unhappy and depressing i
can't i tell a [ __ ] it ain't
that's not a such thing as you can't
that's a yes some way if you keep trying
wow
yeah that's a good attitude yeah i
recently been thinking that like
whatever i thought if i have a thought
it becomes a feeling so i got to be real
careful about what my thoughts are yeah
because if you say if you tell yourself
that you're not good your mind will make
your whole body feel like you're not him
and and i've just learned that i learned
that actually from a teacher her name
was miss troupe she said you can do and
be anything in the [ __ ] world you
want to be the dumbest question is the
question not x and i've that made me ask
people any [ __ ] thing i wanted to ask
them but it's so funny because a lot of
people will hear a teacher say something
like that right and
because probably teachers say that to
everybody in a way but it's a lot of
time it doesn't activate in us you know
i wonder what made it that act you know
what i'm saying it's kind of interesting
how
this teacher spent a lot of time with me
because i was i grew up in the inner
city of atlanta in the ghetto and and
she would you know like she taught me
how to read and and you know she just
instilled a lot of things in me that my
mama did yeah and i'm i'm 50 now and i
still quote her to this day wow when i'm
down and out i said miss troops that i
can do and being the [ __ ] thing i
want to be when i went to my husband
said i'm gonna be a comedian he's like
girl because i'm a convicted fellow he's
like just keep the [ __ ] job at
general moto i'm like no
i i want to be a comedian this [ __ ] look
easy i'm having fun you get to eat cause
everybody start doing comedy well at
least i did to eat the free food and
drinks and [ __ ] yeah it's nice and he's
like i get to eat it and hey you get
that little attention and i was like
just keep the [ __ ] job in general i
say no
i'm gonna be a [ __ ] comedian he's
like oh no this [ __ ] just don't want to
work
[Laughter]
that is true a lot of comedians they
because part of the temptation the
beginning is this [ __ ] does not feel
like a real job it feels kind of if you
have a natural acclimation of being
making people laugh you're like this
[ __ ] is easy it's easy it's fun you
hanging out with people you like you up
all night you get them twenty thirty
dollars and you know them if you look
especially like if you ain't got no real
bills uh or you are you a waiter or
something and you go to your job during
the day but it's so much fun at night to
hang around people that you really
[ __ ] like that do what you do and you
watch everybody turn that [ __ ]
happiness into a struggle where they
trying to make it or trying to make this
[ __ ] work for them so this is all they
got to do because this is what they love
to do yeah
yeah there is something that's kind of
beautiful about it in that sense you
know
do you think sometimes i feel like
strippers i notice a similarity between
strippers and comedians do you ever feel
that way a little bit now i don't know a
goddamn thing about strippers i'm fatter
than a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] man
you think i know alien stripper what's
gonna be next for you theo i don't know
[ __ ] about i don't even go no [ __ ]
strip club i don't even like [ __ ] i
don't like my own [ __ ] so why am i
going to look at other people
you need to stay the [ __ ] out of them
i don't like them either i'm just
thinking
everyday you do you asking me i've
noticed that company and [ __ ] go
together not for me
i don't know [ __ ] about no god damn
scripture fat [ __ ] built like me do
videos like
lizzo liza got shot didn't see it when i
got shot or not no you getting your
black folks mixed up that was uh making
a stand you got shot in the foot lizzie
was the the plus side won't he'll be
giving it to him on the internet he's
gonna be throwing that thick at you yeah
[Laughter]
she look like if you grab her she'll
slip out your hand
oh you can't even get a hug on her you
can't even lock a hug i don't know what
kind of cocoa butter they use on lizzo
but i be like her ass is shiny and she
be throwing that flat at your ass
she's beautiful bro i love me some lizzo
that's hilarious
um so why did you say you think comedy
and uh strippers go together because
it's like putting yourself out there
there's something about it like it's d
you're like putting whatever you have
inside of you out there both of us naked
because once you get on stage the script
is naked as a comedian you really don't
know if they're gonna last so you're
naked too yeah until you grab control
until you learn how to slide down that
pole yeah yeah yeah yeah so i i would
agree with you a little bit a little bit
don't go i don't go to strip club i
don't i don't smell that [ __ ] in hell
yeah that's i guess that's true
i never real i guess well i remember the
first time i ever went me and my friend
lance were in uh louisville
and i was too young to get in but he
could get in so he'd go in and tell me
what it looked like and he'd come back
out and tell me and you know
show me the shape of the breasts with
his hands and everything like that you
know
he come in so he oh was you 10 no i was
probably 16 but we tried and they
wouldn't let me in so he'd just be
describing everything to me and i was
sitting in the car did you get off with
that have me a couple beers i don't
remember if i did i probably did
is 16 having a cup of beers i mean i you
know i was just excited to stay in the
vehicle you know so he went inside and
he would come back out and just i'm
sorry you drinking bills at 16 yeah
where are you from i'm from louisiana oh
no wonder y'all you probably buying gay
putting hickeys on alligator necks and
scenes we did some they definitely had a
lot of i'm trying to think we had a lot
of look we had a lot of different
animals in our area because i grew up in
an area nobody had pets people just had
animals you know like you would just see
an animal in your neighborhood you know
like a cat or you would see somebody or
just a dog would be there you know i
didn't grow up in an area with a lot of
like well they gave a [ __ ] about the
animal oh dude i remember the first time
i ever saw a dog in somebody's house bro
and they loved it that [ __ ] blew my mind
man i
when i was coming up you didn't dogs
wasn't in the house you could time up to
a tree yeah and i think i did that bit
on my special i was like you do that
[ __ ] now you going to [ __ ] jail you
can't tie the dogs up to the trees
anymore i mean dog house dog houses are
obsolete you can't [ __ ] use them they
literally got to be treated like you and
i was like [ __ ] you you can't you don't
even work yeah so why am i treating you
like me yeah at least the dogs in alaska
and stuff they're doing sled and they
doing work during the day but yeah these
just a lot of local animals bro they
really just a lot of them don't pull
their weight you know don't pull they
wait
you say they didn't have a home so they
just hanging out on the corner like the
that's more normal but once people got
him inside yeah it definitely got a
little bit weird keeps baby you got to
keep it
you want it you got to keep it some
people a man can't grow a mustache can't
grow a full hair
well
you can't lose it you got to hold on to
what you got
remember that song hold on to what you
got i've never heard that song
but keeps
they'll help you two out of three men
will experience some form of hair loss
by the time they are 35
so
keep what you have
keeps offers convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
so you're gonna have your meds it's
coming it's discreet your neighbor's not
going to know oh gosh
oh harold's going bald
it's 24 7 care and support keeps has a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers
and care specialists to support you in
making your hair goals
reality
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month and keeps
offers generic versions of the two fda
approved medications to prevent hair
loss i take the medications i stay on
them
you stay on them too if you want to keep
it if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
t-h-e-o to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash theo to get your first month
free keeps.com
theo this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp
is there something interfering with your
happiness
think about that is there something
interfering with your happiness
can you manage it yourself
if you can't
well better help is available
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
they want you to start living a happier
life today
the services available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist
that's priceless that immediate contact
yep
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting additional therapists in all
50 states
special offer for this past weekend
listeners yup that's you guys
if you're struggling
i've been there i've used better help
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o oh thank you that's my gay
daughter she let me give her a gay shout
out oh yeah she is
and she's very beautiful we'll have to
put her picture on her instagram up
okay dang there you go and so does she
let you pick out any of the ladies she
likes her mother doesn't matter uh she
be picking out them little rough [ __ ]
she does yeah
them gang but she likes what do you mean
like the w and like the centers
no she just she's rolling with them
shooting guards oh they're shooting
guards no they be big [ __ ]
maybe i don't know she
we have a running joke with her she
don't keep them long yeah yeah they got
to make it a three thanksgiving before
they really be a part of the family that
makes sense kind of i think that's
realistic
do um
do a lot of uh
is it do people keep being gay a secret
more in black culture than they do you
think and
i mean i only know really white culture
you know i was around black culture like
growing up but i wasn't black so i could
just guess you know
um but if you like if you around black
culture you you know black culture
i i didn't grow around white people but
i moved around and i lit i realized they
love leaving [ __ ] at your door they
baked food
what was your question
yeah it's kind of like prison a little
bit they didn't bring you a baked good
yeah i always bring your [ __ ] baked
goods i mean when i live in any now i'm
like god damn white people stop bringing
[ __ ] to the door we ain't even eating
this [ __ ]
but my neighbors were great in
plainfield indiana what was your
question um
do is it more okay
it was when i was coming up they just
call them punks when i was coming up you
don't give a [ __ ] what you say do you i
don't know
that's what they called him when i was
coming up but like when my daughter came
out and i'm 50. so i would use the word
bull dagger and she was like mama you
can't say the word boy dyker and i'm
like why she said cuz nobody says that
anymore and it's just like a white
person called you in word i was like
when the [ __ ] did they change it today
so
on my sitcom we did a whole episode
about using derogatory words and you
can't say stuff like they're called
lesbians uh-huh a studs so you can't say
bulldogs and there's punks and you can't
call them yeah they can't say it you
lose your [ __ ] you you lose
everything or you'll gain a lot of
people that talk that just believe in
just saying whatever they want that's
what i think about you i think i'm a fan
because she says what she wants to say
she i get the real her well i do i do
but i'm not if if i find out something
hurt you right i'm not gonna see it like
i tell you when i moved to indiana to be
honest with you i had never heard of the
word [ __ ]
and i was at a comedy club and this bla
this comedian called this white lady a
[ __ ] and she just boo hoo and i was like
what the [ __ ] is the [ __ ] and why she
crying like that and she and one of the
committee like that is like a black man
called you a [ __ ] i was like hold on
white girl stop crying let's whoop this
[ __ ] ass
but i didn't know that so if i know that
you if i know something is going to hurt
you
i won't say it to you know
so i'm not going to say the f word i'm
not going i'm not going to call a
lesbian a bulldog because that is
derogatory but you know if i'm at the
house my daughter might get everything
yeah and that's okay that's different
yeah that's different that's different
yeah i think people don't delineate kind
of what is different or what isn't
different you know
yeah you don't want to do anything you
know to hurt anyone but words have
changed you know i think i think this
generation
of people is a lot softer
you know they can't take the [ __ ] we
used to take you know they out you know
when we got bullied we just [ __ ] got
bullied and [ __ ] dealt with it and
showed the bullet 20 years later when
they fat and i had all the kids you
ain't [ __ ] these kids here immediately
you know can't take
criticism and stuff like that they you
know they want to jump off a [ __ ]
bridge
you know it's like it's times have
changed so much where back in the day
when you were working i don't know if it
was hidden from us
or we just you know we just see it more
now like crabby oh that's interesting
yeah because before if somebody took
their life or something or we didn't
really hear about it no and now it's
like boom in your face you know this
person like why you know life is
beautiful but then
mental illness was not a fur
forefront like it is today mental
illness used to be hilarious man you see
somebody that's mentally ill you're like
[ __ ] dog yeah they really it was your
uncle's and you know you wanted him
every uncle and uh every uncle was
mentally ill not everybody you know
everybody is 60 70
yeah we had a few that was you know but
now you can't pick at that stuff anymore
yeah you got to say
what the hell oh yeah rodney's not doing
well you got to say stuff like that yeah
yeah sometimes just have changed you
know we we have to put up
we i think the world has have held us to
caring a little bit more caring about
each other you think
we should but yeah it's trying to get
there yeah i think that's a good point i
think it is trying to get there
do you think oh what was halloween like
in a black community what was that i
always wondered what that's like
it's like
i've heard comedian makes jokes about
you go to the white neighborhood to get
the big snickers
[Laughter]
but um it was like you just like every
other halloweens i don't think
um i know in my community they didn't go
out on costumes like they do today and i
think it had a lot to do with people
couldn't afford them or they really
wasn't into one yeah and like my
mother-in-law she didn't believe in
halloween because she thought it was the
devil's day because she was super
christian and [ __ ] so you wasn't they
wasn't allowed to go trick-or-treating
and put on costumes and [ __ ] like that
but we were just going all regular
clothes yeah
yeah oh that's interesting
yeah i think uh we used to get like oh
my dad was real old my dad was 70 when i
was born he was an old man
yeah that he was 70. yeah he was 70 he
was born in 1910 right so he was real
old
so he how the hell did that happen your
mom was selling [ __ ] no she was just
giving it out
and um but how was your mother 32 my
mother was 32 was your daddy rich no
and that's the crazy part
was they in tennessee no they was in
louisiana
are you serious yeah
yeah mama [ __ ] a 90 year old me i mean
70. yeah yeah 70. and he was handsome
guy but how long was he around after he
was born two weeks 86.
[Laughter]
it felt like it man he was every time
every day i saw him like damn he's
getting smaller and smaller he's about
to meet me in the middle
that's what i feel like your daddy was
86 yeah how was you when he died
16.
so i was getting pretty old but um jesus
[ __ ] christ yeah so it was why your
mama said she i'm interested why your
momma would [ __ ] somebody that old did
she did she need her [ __ ] trailer
paid for i don't know what she needed
my mother doesn't say anything about it
yes she doesn't say anything about it is
you the only well of course you don't
know we got four children i got two
years not by that old man yeah
not by that old man
you might need to check your dna i
guarantee you that was a younger [ __ ]
up the street a younger person up the
street baby and you just put it on that
old man because he was taking care of
the house baby i don't he wasn't taking
care of much man dude the best things
i'm trying to think uh
my dad bought a cutlass right because we
lived right we lived in like in a black
and white neighborhood so my dad bought
a cutlass from a couple brothers around
the corner from us and it had like 22s
in the trunk right
so
he and he was
he couldn't even hear right so he would
drive around listening to paul harvey
you remember that guy on the radio who
did like the weather report it was like
pole or like the old
dude he would listen to it would just it
would have had a ton of bass though it'd
be like the weather and like uh
it was like am radio and [ __ ] he would
listen to rush limbaugh just boom
you're dead it was a rush limbo person
yeah but he would listen to it with like
a ton of bass though it's different when
you're here with bass oh i bet it is
he's screaming he's screaming to a beat
but it was a little bit different that
was interesting i guess
i can't get over your daddy who's your
granddad
my grandfather was born in 1880 which is
crazy
him and your daddy went to school
together
was he alive when you when you were born
no no he was gone that's the only reason
why your daddy got your mama because
your dad your granddad had already died
[ __ ] i've heard [ __ ] for rent money
but that's a look that's [ __ ] for
social security yeah that's the crazy
part i was like who's [ __ ] why i
wouldn't i just didn't understand still
alive yeah she's still alive don't tell
me she got another old man oh no she she
married another guy but he was only 20
years older but he ended up passing away
but
everybody died with your mama too
[ __ ] yo mama like that's soft dick yeah
[ __ ]
she got like something how the [ __ ] a 70
year old man get no i don't know do um
yeah i guess maybe people's penises get
softer over time i don't know
i'm not sure
i just know how much i mean i know how
you know my own penis over my own time
but i don't how old are you i'm 40 years
old i'm 41. it's coming damn
i don't want that man
nobody wants it but it can't stay hard
forever i'm telling you yo if that's
your daddy your mama's swallowed
i don't mean to be mean well i just
don't see no 70 year old man back
back what do you know viagra to help
your daddy out back then so you got it
so if they had no viagra he was doing
that on sheer willpower and there's
something beautiful about that no ain't
no 70 year old man you
cause you talk like a brother too you
just got that joe dirk got a big ass
baby i do have kind of a big ass you
know we'll say that
black men ain't got no big ass i'm just
saying
you might need to check your dna you
might be a little bit of black oh dude
i'll take a little yeah
yeah i'll take a little if i could get
it you know i wonder how you get that
white kid that gets really obsessed with
black culture like you know it's it's
funner
it's it's like it's a cool thing to do
and i felt like those kids i you know i
just like we rode on the same bus
it's funny because you say your daddy
listen to rush limbaugh yeah but that
was him that's cause i think that was
just another senior citizen you know
but he didn't try to spill that over
into your life no he wasn't
no no my dad wasn't racist i think he
was just a republican but he wasn't
right he wasn't like a racist guy our
family wasn't like our family wasn't
like redneck or anything my dad was from
nicaragua and my mom was from illinois
but how the [ __ ] you end up with the
redneck haircut
it only looked good on you cause you
been rocking that [ __ ] for a long
no you remind me of vanilla ice
[Laughter]
ice ice baby
i actually love that [ __ ] song it was
good huh well i heard you talking about
used to watch leave it to beaver i i
grew up watching yeah i used to like
live through the television shows yeah
so how do you think if you grew up like
in such an environment that was probably
so dangerous what do you really think i
know you too
oh okay yeah yeah sorry i mean because
you got to think um
if you know black culture back in those
days we wasn't
all of this black on black violence
wasn't happening that didn't happen to
crack hit the black community yeah then
that [ __ ] happened so when i was growing
up it was just crazy it was just um
poverty
you know it was just poverty that's what
it was
you know and when you when you poor like
that as a kid you really don't know you
poor until you grow up and then look in
society tell you because a lot of [ __ ]
i didn't really learn that was wrong
until i became so i opened my mouth
about it and i became a comedian and i
was like people like i didn't grow up
like that and i was like you didn't grow
up like that your mom they cook in the
fireplace what the [ __ ] are your mama
doing cooking in the fireplace can we
handle
so you know it was just poverty we were
just poor as hell yeah being poor
creates the most fun though cause you
got to be around each other more you
don't have things that occupy your time
i think you see more [ __ ] you do see
more [ __ ] you learn you learn something
called survivor yeah less stuff is
hidden from you
so i think when you're wealthy you get
to hide more you hide from other people
you can hide more from you get hedges
you get a yard you get distance between
you get separate bedrooms you get all
these things where like everything is
kind of hidden
we had edges they were just walked on we
had a yeah we just walked
[Laughter]
wait a minute theo we all had everything
rich people had it just didn't look as
good as they [ __ ] did yeah
uh and we just cooked in a fireplace but
yeah i think
when you when you're wealthy um
you know
a lot more is given you know and when
you pour you got to earn a lot more yeah
even with my kids i mean i'm not rich or
no [ __ ] like that but you know but y'all
getting fancier is it harder to not pat
is it harder to make your kids have the
same struggle that you had is that tough
well they don't have the same struggle
because their struggle ain't there no
more so
uh it's i have to learn to say no
i was like go get your own [ __ ] don't
tell me what you can't do when your
mama's sitting here with an eighth grade
education and the ged and look what the
[ __ ] i did now what the [ __ ] you gonna
do yeah so
and i i don't have a problem with
telling them no yeah yeah get the [ __ ]
on there's my money no i'm not gonna do
that for you i'ma show you how to do it
for yourself
which one how many children do you have
of your own i have four 35 34 22 and 23.
and which one was probably the
was it giving birth do you tell me about
that do you ever have any crazy giving
birthdays like days where you had to go
to the hospital and give birth because i
know you had a wild you had like a w
you've had a wild life you know very
wild compared to a lot of folks well i
uh my first one i had at 14 that was
real easy
she popped out i can't even think about
that it feels illegal for me to even
think about that birthday
i can't even look at pictures from that
that's crazy i know right but i gave
birth at 14 and that was the easiest
pregnancy ever i mean she literally
popped out and i was riding my bicycles
in three days wow so um how big was she
you think she was nine pounds and my
last child was ten two
he really hurt
and he always been like that kind of a
pain a little
well you know i a lot of parents don't
tell you this but i always tell them i
said i love all of my kids but every
parent got a favorite kid and then last
one is my favorite yeah and you tell it
oh yeah i tell them i said i love all
y'all but this is my favorite right here
what makes him a favorite i think cause
he was the last one he was 10-2 and
um that my husband didn't have any kids
when i met him so he took care of my my
two kids and my sister four kids then i
had a daughter buying
and then when i had my last one was a
boy and i wanted to name it after him
and i kind of think that's why junebug
is my favorite because he's a junior oh
yeah
yeah we had a june bug bus growing up we
had a kid named junebug
junebug was everywhere everybody got a
junebug oh really
i think so yeah
i'm trying to think we stab i was always
in these black people had the cool
exciting names but i had theo and i got
to meet malcolm jamal warner one time
and i told him that my name was theo he
didn't really care but that's all right
what the [ __ ] you want me to do because
you hey that anybody could be named theo
i probably gave you the same reaction
what [ __ ] you want me to say oh we got
saying daddy you're dead at 99.
wow i'll say this business is off to a
good start this year you know we're
doing business and you know who else's
business did well last year
santa that's right
and when he can't bring all the gifts he
ships them he uses ship station
online shipping isn't slowing down
anytime soon
brook and mortal stores are disappearing
everybody in the mail
everybody
is your business
ready to keep up the pace that's a great
question ask yourself if you don't have
a business ask yourself anyway man who
cares ship station is already trusted by
over 100 000 e-commerce sellers those
are businesses you can keep track of
orders from any sales channel find the
best shipping carrier with deeply
discounted rates and automate just about
any shipping task with just a few clicks
save time by funneling all your orders
into one simple interface no matter what
you're selling
whether it's through amazon etsy or your
own website shipstation makes it easy
ship more in less time with shipstation
use my offer code t-h-e-o to get a
60-day free trial that's two months of
no hassle stress free shipping just go
to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in th eo ship station
make ship happen
it's the beginning of a new year that's
right it is the beginning of a new year
so there's never been a better time to
get back in shape have you thought about
that
that's right and you can start the year
off with a 25
off
a fit bod membership
yep it's you know springtime is when you
want to get ready for summer summer's
coming
so if you put yourself on a you know a
six eight week plan you can be ready
to have a little bit more body comfort
in the summer
some of my fitness goals this year to
get my shoulders back
and to
do yoga
and also do push-ups and i've been doing
them
and you know who can help you do them
fit bod that's right
fitbots algorithm uses data to create
and adjust a dynamic fitness plan just
for you
you'll have access to your own
personalized routine on their easy to
use mobile app so you can start making
progress on your goals anytime
anywhere now that's one thing that i do
think is pretty fascinating about fit
bod
is the way they're able to curtail it
to you
a lot of different programs can't do
that kick the new year off right and get
started on your customized fitness plan
from fit bod whether you exercise three
days a week or twice a day every workout
is scientifically proven to be better
than the last
get 25 off your membership now when you
sign up at fit bod dot m e
slash t-h-e-o that's 25 off your
membership at fit bod
f-i-t-b-o-d dot m-e slash theo you got
any kids
no i would like to get one i've been i
get i'm ready i think to get married i
think i'm talking about having a getting
a wife
you you talking about getting the white
are you dating theo i'm doing a little
bit of light dating but i'm ready to
really i think step it up
really i think so i'm ready
i'm ready to have a couple children
maybe now you um
you dating more than one woman are you
dating one woman i'm dating a little bit
of more than one
you know uh you're gonna say that on
your pocket like the hoes don't listen
to your pocket okay
i don't think i mean i i'm still looking
you know i'm still looking how'd you
know when you met your husband that he
was the one
uh he had a good job back teeth and he
didn't hit [ __ ] in the eye on friday
damn but um i knew he was the one he was
a nice guy did you know him right from
the beginning or took a little few dates
i liked him so yeah
you know he just came over and we went
out a couple times but i liked him when
i first saw him
what kind of man do you think if out of
the gate he's kind of like in that gray
zone
what can he do on that second third date
to maybe get himself into a better zone
you think what do you mean by gray zone
like if you're not liking him you're
just not sure maybe you're kind of like
you're never not sure when you meet
somebody i think the more the
conversation a person can learn a lot
about you through your conversation i
mean if you i mean if you're listening
good
some women get swindled through
conversations because they
some memes know how to say all the right
[ __ ] oh yeah or you hang up their phone
you got to take a step back like what
this [ __ ] up to yeah you know
and then i mean
times have changed so much now
[ __ ] name you can you can call
a girlfriend like my friend quiche [ __ ]
put this [ __ ] name in this
thing and tell me more about this person
and it'll bring up everything about them
yeah it's hard to hide now it's hard to
hide now so i mean you just can't you
can't be google guy guy over somebody
the first
sometime the first [ __ ] year you just
gotta keep talking and and see if it
grows yeah
do you think sometimes i feel like black
people don't get that nervous i always
feel like black people don't get nervous
do you feel like black people get
nervous or not
we human
what the [ __ ] you think we are animals
no honest people
don't get there what the [ __ ] are you
talking about a lot of my friends they
never seem like they get nervous nervous
about what you don't get nervous i get
nervous i get nervous a lot so i'm also
a person that gets extra nervous so then
i think i'm more prone to maybe thinking
that some people don't get nervous
uh you probably think
i would i think i think it's not the
word nervous you probably think we
is he thinking we bad ass are we just
like we don't give a [ __ ]
i don't know what it is maybe we don't
get scared maybe it's a mix of some of
those things and so then it comes off to
me like that oh my black friends don't
get nervous we get nervous
let us get pulled over by the police
you got that right we get nervous yeah i
guess that's a good problem
i mean that's a real game yeah once that
[ __ ] happens man that [ __ ] is but you
know you you no whammies
know what no whammies i was saying it's
like a game show that said it's a
dangerous game show if you get pulled
over by the cops man but not for all
cops because i'm not the one to say all
cops are bad cops you know i try to tell
people about time you can't throw that
one let that one person throw that whole
race of people off i know because that's
not fair yeah because there's a lot of
good guys and then people come at them
with a bad energy it's like when um the
guy from uh he might be your friend but
uh from um
who was on xm radio what's his name
oh uh
um he was on xml radio they was on for
years and patrice moby and anthony yeah
wasn't it opie or anthony they cussed
out the black woman i'm not sure she
made the video one of them made the
video probably it might be anthony
anthony's more
like volatile yeah so he made the video
saying
black women or something and all he had
to say was
that [ __ ] he had that incident
was the problem but when you throw a
whole when you throw all black women in
it then it becomes a problem because i'm
not that lady who cuts you out right so
while you throwing my race because you
dealt with somebody that we are the same
race that's not fair if if if a white
boy run up and
uh rape me i'm not gonna say all white
boys rape yeah that's not fair i mean
you wouldn't rape me would you um i
wouldn't
why are you saying um first
that ain't how you ask a rape question i
mean i wanted to really
you know you had to think twice
i would not be raping i ain't doing no
raping okay so i'm not even that good at
sex i'd be the worst rapist ever let me
know
worse that sex that's why they take it
and they force their [ __ ] on you but so
i just think i just think you cannot
throw stuff on people because one person
individuals did it yeah it doesn't make
everybody that race the same way
how long were you doing comedy before
you were before something started to
turn and you're like oh wow this is
going to be good because i've seen you
go through the clubs for a long time oh
yeah um
probably 12 13 years maybe 15 at the
most
and what was the thing that started to
kind of when did you start to see oh
something's changing here
i um i moved to indiana which i thought
my life was gonna be [ __ ] over
and so um
i ended up getting on a tour with cat
william the cat apocalypse tour oh wow
right after i moved i was and cat paid
me [ __ ] like
a [ __ ] ton of money to do 15 minutes a
night
and then i ended up going on the road
with rnas j and d ray davis and i just
kept grinding but i knew i knew by me
being on that cat tour and you know i
did festivals and [ __ ] like that and
that had really helped me out because
red grant was he on there too or no red
ground was on the one i was on he's on
all of them but he was on that one i was
on but it i just felt like that's when i
thought
you know a lot of [ __ ] started to kind
of change for me yeah
and along with festivals i stayed going
to the festival even if i wasn't invited
like montreal because you know as a
young comic you automatically think oh
if i go to mutual if i just get new
faces my whole life's gonna change
change that is that is that
i try to tell you i said hey just go
over and do the [ __ ] jokes it's a
goddamn it's a good time yeah it's a
good time i remember the year i went and
it was the year of the white boy so
white boys was really hot and i didn't
realize that after i was there and it
was after this connect everybody was all
up this canadian comedian ass which i
didn't think was funny but i didn't know
i'm a young comic so i don't know what
the industry is looking for right and i
did my set and nobody said anything to
me but when they tell you oh my god the
industry's gonna be all over you you're
gonna do this you're gonna do that
nobody talked to me and i remember going
back to my hotel room and crying because
everybody told me if i go over there i
was gonna blow the [ __ ] up then i had to
realize
this [ __ ] is a process
and it might take it might not never
happen yeah so i just started to focus
on my comedy and when i got invited to
[ __ ] i would show up and and i just
learned to take the feelings out of it
because when you got feelings out in it
you will [ __ ] go crazy
that's a really good point yeah i
remember getting invited not getting
invited to those things and thinking man
i'm never gonna have a chance this this
industry doesn't like me this whole
world doesn't you know
that i'm not a part of it was you a new
face no
really i never was yeah
and then it started to get you know now
it's really it's about like diversity
and a lot of like trans comedian gay you
know it's a lot of that now and i don't
need it now you know
in my own kind of world now once
podcasting started people could create
their own worlds yeah they could they
really could
um
i just think it's more about diversity
so it's a lot about diversity i think
the the the industry was forced to
listen to what everybody had to say yeah
well you need more voices at a certain
point you kind of have heard a lot of
the same voice yeah because i mean let's
be honest if it's a white girl it's the
same [ __ ] white girl thing and then
i've seen so many other white comedian
white female comedian that wasn't [ __ ]
but wasn't getting pushed to the top
right and i'm like well this [ __ ] is
funny right but it doesn't get you know
when you when you [ __ ] it was like
there they'll push you to the top and
everybody knows they knew that at the
time so i just think it's it's what the
industry believed that divorce they're
looking for that season
well i've always thought earthquake i've
always thought is one of the best
comedians nobody's [ __ ] funny i mean
who kills a room who kills a room i've
always said earthquake is probably one
of the top three that i've seen who
kills a room and to finally see him
getting you know getting a netflix
special and just do you have one things
that make him feel deserved you know
because a part of it is making him feel
does like
you deserve that you know not you des
but just like a thing where it's like
you've earned this yes yes yes a piece
of him can be like okay i have you know
i mean because we we as comics let's be
real we sat at the house and was like
how did this [ __ ] get this this
[ __ ] ain't even funny you said
behind the door who the [ __ ] pushing
this person so that's what i mean when i
say i learned to take the feelings out
of it so now i say oh well you know
um maybe more black girls will get
specials right i was so happy when they
gave tiffany that special
and uh and monique made all of that
noise about um you know the pay of women
and stuff
and you know i was happy because
i'm gonna be honest i think
netflix started to give more black women
stuff
after that right you know
where i didn't see a lot of black
females getting special especially ones
that stepped outside of the box so
that's a good point huh yeah never even
thought about that yeah and then you
know i don't know what tiffany got paid
but i heard she got paid really good i
mean it was really good to me too
so you know i just think it made them
pay attention hey you it's not enough
diversity on your platform which they
they turn it around and they put a lot
of diversity on it you know i like when
i see a gay or trans or black or white
or hispanic or uh or any uh asian
comedian yeah that means it's a little
bit it's something out there for
everybody it's like a gumbo yeah instead
of just one straight way
yeah
you know i used to think about that when
i was young it would be like actually a
lot of my favorite shows it was like
i mean what did they have like
i mean i loved uh
a lot of my favorite sitcoms and stuff
were black shows you know good times the
jeffersons what was uh
family matters people love that show
yeah people love that show my show is uh
uh the show that i do the miss pat show
it's it's kind of like they want to say
a roseanne because i'm i'm a i'm a
plus-sized woman like roseanne but
i think it's more like archie bonker
like yeah yeah that type of honesty
and and the family that one yeah all in
the family i have a lot of learning
moments like him yeah so um
but peop but sometimes sometimes i'm
shooting i tell myself i tell my
co-creator jordan cooper i said
something it feel like martin's then
they feel like a burning mac so it's a
little bit of mix of everything well you
look like gina from martin a little bit
the lady that played in that show really
i've never heard that one really mike my
the father on the show wife looks a lot
like her to me oh really yeah yeah
um we have a couple questions that came
in do you want to pull something up
colin okay
hey what's up miss pat what's up theo um
my question is for miss pat uh i was a
photographer at skankfest last november
and miss pat was there and so was so is
the great bob saget and um you know miss
patton and bob talk a lot about their
friendship and their relationship you
know on podcasts during the week and
stuff and but i was just wondering is
there a favorite moment you have ms pat
uh you know or a favorite uh
story about bob that you have we'd love
to hear it thanks guys gang gang gang
baby thanks for the question man
um
yeah bob sage came to my house for
dinner did he really i did bob saget um
podcast
and when we when we logged off and you
know i found out i said you planning
indy i live he's like why don't i come
to your house for dinner and i'm like
what the [ __ ] you know i'm like you
wanna go to my [ __ ] house for
dinner and so he really threw me off and
i'm like okay
and so i didn't really know if he was
gonna come wow so and at the time i'm in
atlanta trying to buy a house and get
our stuff together i had a gig and i had
to get rid of that date that bob said
that thursday because i was not going to
tell bob say he could not come to my
[ __ ] house so i just i went home and
i cleaned up i called the housekeeping
and i was like what the [ __ ] is going on
i have a really famous person coming to
the house but i can't tell y'all who it
is because i didn't know if bob sagan
was gonna show the [ __ ] up like you did
you know how famous people stand you up
oh yeah and then they was like well
who's coming and i would never tell them
who came and i just said wait till they
ring the doorbell and everybody trying
to figure out [ __ ] who coming he
rings the doorbell he got flowers in his
hand and why they they was like bob sage
[Laughter]
oh my god and we sat down and i wish i'd
have videoed the whole thing when i tell
you he was so [ __ ] funny and you know
you're thinking bob sang it you know the
clean bumps take it from the sitcom
corny as [ __ ] you know you know but i've
seen his stand up i knew his standup was
funny i just said he was so [ __ ]
quick with it he was like just cracking
the [ __ ] he had us cracking up like
seriously and then we my son barbecue
because my son junebug can barbecue
really well so i'm like jumbo you gonna
barbecue and gary ella's gonna make this
like who the [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up i
said just cook the food and i can't cook
so
we made this barbecue and i bought
steaks and you know i'm like i don't
know what the [ __ ]
you know rich people eat or how they eat
so i just went out about the best of
everything and um
bob sagan ate a plate he's like oh my
god this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] good he got
up and when he fixed himself another
place
saw that and then he did i was like hold
on bob you want to buy grocery
[ __ ]
he's like he's been a long time since i
had food this good miss pellet what the
[ __ ] have you been and he was there for
about four or five hours and we left at
that table and we talked and and that's
my that's my most memorable moment with
him wow that's wild that's amazing huh
yeah and your family your kids were
there too my uh my whole family was
there it sure was i flew i flew uh my
the girl who do my hair and i was like
he might not come because i told her who
he was but i didn't tell my family and
we just waited he wrung that door but he
got in an uber damn he got out the
[ __ ] uber like a nice uber a regular
one it was a regular little but i don't
even think the person who picked bob sag
it up knew they would bob said he had a
mask on oh yeah
yeah
damn and and so we take some pictures
and i post them and everybody bob sagan
was in our neighborhood
oh that's my most memorable i tell you
when um i found out he passed i couldn't
stop crying yeah because it was such a
building relationship like bob sage
would literally
text me in the middle of now how are you
doing bada and i just talked to him
because
you know i asked bob to be on my show
and i was my show was on bt plus and
pair my plus and you know i know bob
ain't never been on bt so i said i'm
gonna ask him a minute i said would you
come and play you know a role on the
chase like [ __ ] yeah i'm there so we
were literally talking about him you
know doing a role on the show yeah and
um
um the week the week he died i had just
text him and say send it up he's telling
me who to reach out to and i got you pat
i'm gonna do it
and i was leaving a falcon game and my
son called and said they said bob sega
died and i called
and was no answer and i was like this
can't be real
and i lit i i literally [ __ ] cried i
was like
because i really liked it he was so
[ __ ] genuine
he was just a genuine guy and i'm the
type of person like i don't give a [ __ ]
who you are or what you've done
if you're a good person then i [ __ ] with
you yeah and he was a good person wow
man that's what kind of makes me sad
yeah he was a good person to him and
sometimes i go back and i look at and
you know i started seeing people posting
a text message between uh them and bob
saget i was like i would never do that
some of that's a little weird you know i
think showing some support is one thing
trying to relate too much i don't when
people do that [ __ ] they over relate
that [ __ ] to me is well that's you want
clout on it online too you want i would
never show something that private
because you died
and to go and show people my text
message between me and bob say i just i
wouldn't do that you know and then
like i had an actress on the show that
committed suicide who played his
secretary
and i just talked to her a week before
and she was about to return to the show
and that [ __ ] just hit me like a brick
because she was she was like my baby you
know i don't know i when i meet people
is because i grew up like
not not a close-knit family and
i just started to collect people as
family members and she was like a family
member to me
and you know
what was about three weeks ago she was
here she was missing and then she um she
they found her um they said she
committed suicide so did you have any
inkling when you saw her did she seem
down you could you'd have no idea i
don't
you know you don't really
she was i had a nervous energy to me
like
like always something wrong but she
didn't want to disappoint people and i
was talking to her about a role and i
was like that role is too small you too
[ __ ] good so look i'm gonna bring you
in for this role and and we back and
forth and i come off stage and i got
this long ass secret i said you i called
i said you okay he's like i just don't
want to disappoint you and i was like
lindsay i [ __ ] love you and you know
no no you know and i was like just wait
and the week she killed herself as a
week she was supposed to be on my
[ __ ] show well she was that was the
episode she was gonna come in for but i
told her it was too small i was gonna
bring in for the next so we literally
writing her in the next one and as i
come off stage they said she was missing
and i talked to another uh one of the
actors from l.a on my show
and then they well two days later they
said she was dead and i was like i can't
believe she did this damn
that's scary yeah it's very scary you
know because i mean as
because
i i sometimes i beat myself i was like
[ __ ] if i had just given her that small
role that's she could have been there
with me and she wouldn't have killed
herself
yeah i have a gut there's a guy like who
used to hit me up uh i met him through
skydiving right i met him at a comedy
show one time and he said hey man i'm
such a big fan i can relate to you on
certain levels like how you feel about a
lot of things and we swapped numbers he
invited me to go skydiving so i went
down there one time took my little i had
a girlfriend at the time
and she was good girl and we went
skydiving and then a couple like months
after that he'd been messaging me but i
had i just hadn't noticed i'd just been
busy and i just hadn't noticed and he'd
sent like three texts over a couple
months and then he killed himself and
sometimes i think damn man if i just
said my life had been a little slower
or something you know if i hadn't been
thinking about myself
then i'm not saying i could have saved
him but maybe i could have just you just
don't know sometimes how
what people are needing you know i mean
some people some people just need
somebody to listen sometimes and so i
have a and i don't have a lot a lot of
time like i used to because i'm so busy
with tv show radio and just trying to
create other [ __ ] where i try to take
out the time like if i'm waking up at
four o'clock in the morning i don't
really have to be up because my mind
wake me up at that time i stroll through
my messages and i see a lot of people
that need
talking and if i can't say a lot i was
like love you take care how you doing
and i answer back i try to as much as i
can but with a growing career i mean i
don't i hope i get as big as
dave chappelle and kevin hart one day
but i do take time to when they message
me
when i can to say something back yeah
cause sometimes people just need an ear
yeah
yeah it's crazy how we have so much
communication now but nobody really
taking time really to listen nobody's
really available in a lot of ways or we
all feel like we also need to
tell somebody instead of hear them you
know i noticed that a lot we feel this
compulsion i think since we have so many
ways to put things out there that we
have to put things that we i have to i
have to tell them you know i have to
instead of like uh listen i don't know
i don't know that much
yeah
um is that another question
yeah we got one more question that came
in oh
i'ma start this question [ __ ] i did
somebody else's podcast it was kind of
cute
yeah it's nice and people can you know
if they get specific they can really
have something for you
got a question here from miss pat
if you had three options to marry one of
these comedians and live with for the
rest of your entire life
between your boy
theo vaughn
everyone's favorite fat alcoholic
comedian burke kreischer
was slept king himself
bobby lee who are you taking this pat
yeah i believe you handed out a little
vietnamese treat
a little shrimp salad baby
oh my god
can you handle that huh ah
i'm gonna have to choose um then you
look good in that picture
if you think i look good in that yeah
there's something you've done shane
because there's something wrong with you
now i'm about to go bird crashing burn
got that long paper oh yeah that's a
good bert look like you can buy more
wigs and you're okay
and we look like we're wearing wigs
that's the crazy part
but what about bobby you ever date a
little asian man ain't no date out
beside my damn razor there's definitely
not no [ __ ] asian come on i've seen
bobby lee dick too they don't want that
[ __ ] that shit's so small like a
two-piece yeah that thing really don't
even look like
he he got baby nuts so you know
he ain't busting no nothing
inside of you
the asian people they say what a little
wooden shoes to keep their feet from
growing like he stuck his dick in one
would have to be bird crushing for me
baby
damn i like it i seen birdhouse too and
burke liked them southern girl cause his
wife from the same place i'm from
atlanta is she really yes yeah she's
beautiful she's a sweetheart but you do
look like an actress actor in that
picture theo oh thank you yeah yeah i
think about sometimes doing some acting
but i don't know podcasting and touring
kind of keeps me so busy you know did
you always want to be an actress no
i just i love comedy and um because
acting's a different thing it's a
different beast um you know my show was
created through fox and lee dania and
ron howe and brian grazer so um they
immediately got me an acting coach and
it took five years to get that show up
and on tv because hulu shot the pilot
dropped it and then bt plus picked it up
and then paramount it just went over to
paramount plus so um
they just they put a lot of money into
me learning how to act
so but no i i prefer comedy first yeah
but i do i do like creating yeah i do i
have some other things and that i'm
working on i i like behind the camera
yeah it's a lot of [ __ ] work in front
of that camera especially when it's your
show cause you got to memorize lines you
got to write jokes you got to help write
it then you know whenever when all the
other actors go home your ass still up
yeah and you st this is your show so you
gotta still make it great like i
literally gotta leave here and i'm
running to do another show and then on
the plane i'm reading all night yeah
it's a lot of work yeah it's more work
than people think oh it's a lot of
[ __ ] work you're gonna earn them
panties yeah
i agree um
let's get a different one do we have one
more that came in
and then we'll get you oh this past
weekend what's up
you know i'm sitting here all horned up
anyways miss pat i got a question for
you so you talk about how you used to
sell crack cocaine and stuff everybody
knows every neighborhood has that one
funny crackhead
who is the funniest person that you used
to sell crack to
gang you guys have a good one gang baby
i always wanted to smoke crack man oh no
you don't but i think it was i must say
too
if i can remember uh one of them name
was rehab
it was his zoo he said
my street name was rabbit rabbit uh give
me one more rock i'm going to the rehab
so i named the rehab because he never
made it he ended up [ __ ] shooting
some dope and falling out in the street
and die he was so [ __ ] funny and
squirrel was the other one he the only
[ __ ] that bought dope from you
but were rap
give me that sack pack
give me that sack rap he would have a
whole rap every time he came and bought
dope he was saying you a whole song that
was [ __ ] hilarious oh yeah there's
some funny ass cracking some talented
ass crackheads out there too yeah yeah
crack will bring the talent right out of
it it brings it right to the surface
cause you need it so you'll give
whatever you got whatever your talent is
i feel like it'll you you'll display it
uh
you think no i think telling bring the
best talent i mean the best talent crack
bring out of you is dick sucking oh damn
because when you run out of money you
got to do something well i guess you
right then theo
yeah yeah that's true huh
i would never
how far down a crack do you have to beat
it will you get to that were you doing
oral sex out there for another uh two
dollars um
probably at the bottom
but how many times you have to use crack
before you start getting to that like is
there a couple of times i don't know i
never use they say crack is very
addictive the very first time they said
give you a feeling that you'll never get
again wow
and you forever searching for that
feeling damn
that's crazy that they can make that huh
uh yeah
that's crazy it's like they're playing
like they're playing god or something
yeah this [ __ ] is wild out there yeah i
always wanted to smoke it but i've
always been afraid i guess well i'm glad
you didn't because i would hate it see
you say your mullet
miss pat thank you for coming in thank
you for finally [ __ ] having me i know
we've been back and forth back and forth
and i've been ripping and running but i
appreciate you taking taking out the
time and doing it today well i feel
honored and i'm so excited for your
success i'm just really
you know i'm just happy for you you
sound like you have a beautiful voice
and um i think we just need it in the
world so thank you for coming and
spending some time with me and if it
don't work out on the white side theo
come on over here with these uh
beautiful uh cocoa butter rub damn
sisters they'll take would they give me
a chance you think they're gonna change
that haircut but
they're going to put some cornrows in
this [ __ ] dude roll it up i'll put a
jingle bell in that [ __ ] during the
i'm just holidays
you were the smoothest talking white boy
i've seen in my life but dressed like a
white boy put me in coach i'm ready
i'm gonna hook you i gotta quiche y'all
we gotta find theo vaughn a black sister
oh she got with her with that kid huh i
could do i think maybe one kid two kids
seem like a lot two kids
what'd you say
what about six no she got sick
is she really
the lesbian f6 how no the lesbians don't
have anything for your other she eat her
babies
the other girl got sick
oh damn you have six children god damn
baby
wow that thing hit like popcorn
you got to put the off switch on that
[ __ ] you must that thing must be stuck
on
man
we breaking theo we bringing theo vaughn
to the black side i am looking for him a
good black woman out there and i'm gonna
say it on my podcast and we're gonna
hook you up we're gonna take you on
seeing you on a black date i'm ready and
i'll even take a real thug ass woman too
you know what i'm saying i'm ready i
think you can handle thug [ __ ] yeah you
know what i'm saying i want a [ __ ]
that'll [ __ ] she's driving she's
right she picks me up you know what i'm
saying bruh that's what we're gonna end
this park here right here and in the
black community they call it a low down
[ __ ] gonna do that to you
look i don't know what i'm ready for
something thank you miss pam i got you i
got it now i'm just floating on the
breeze and i feel i'm falling like these
leaves i must be
[Music]
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with
[Music]
now
you